les trois meurtres commis à la toile en
pleine rue rappelle à bien des gens la
tac aux sabres survenu il ya deux ans à
québec est un événement à lui chila
terrifiant dans les deux cas les auteurs
avaient de l'eau aux antécédents
psychiatriques donc la question se pose
comment prévenir de tels crimes des
sciences de montréal offrent déjà des
suivis psychiatriques à domicile des
équipes qui sont dans la communauté qui
sont qui font des visites à domicile
donc des suivis intense et d'un milieu à
l'exemple est suivie d'un camp stéphane
riad défi dit qu'ils peuvent tirer au
delà des huit visites par mois selon les
besoins du patient nous suivons des
patients ce qu'on appelle communément
des patients qui ont connu des actes
criminels mais qui sont reconnus
responsables mais pour la criminologue
maria mourani c'était suffisant même si
un suivi on n'est pas capable de savoir
quand il va récidiver alors même si une
infirmière vient le rencontrer à la
maison la semaine avant le délit elle
leur en combi il a l'air de prendre ses
médicaments or à l'institut de
psychiatrie légale philippines elle pour
qu'un patient reprenne sa vie en société
c'est toute une équipe
interdisciplinaire qui l'accompagnent
dans sa réhabilitation
on les envoie par exemple automoteurs
accompagné pendant un certain temps et
même si son évaluation est fondée sur
des critères scientifiques
le docteur dufour est bien conscient des
failles du système je pense que si on
avait plus de ressources surtout pour
les suivants clinique externe mais des
ressources spécialisées en psychiatrie
légale je pense que ça serait bien pour
prévenir des récidives de violence c'est
pourquoi maria mourani demande pour sa
part une meilleure coordination tant
dans la sphère criminel qu'on santé
mentale
et pendant que des familles font le
deuil de leurs proches l'enquète elle
pourra nous éclairer sur les véritables
motivations du tireur à laval et à
montréal
ici gabriel proulx radio canada montréal